welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navaro and this is film
[Music]
rank we create the definitive
authoritative top five ranking list that
will live on in infamy for an eternity
until the end of time today we're
delving deep into the Realms of movie
Magic to uncover the top five film
twists of all time oh and in case you
haven't figured it out already we will
be spoiling these movies you've been
warned now let's get to it at number
five we have the Leonardo DiCaprio
Martin scorsi modern classic shudder
Island scorsese's masterful Direction
combined with an intense performance by
DiCaprio sets the stage for a
psychological Thriller like no
other what the is going on here the film
about a federal Marshall who arrives at
a mental institution looking for a
missing inmate weaves a Sinister and
enigmatic narrative that keeps viewers
guessing until the final shocking
Revelation it turns out that DiCaprio's
baguer character isn't actually a
federal marshal at all but instead a
delusional inmate of the titular
facility what did you do my goddamn gun
like so many of these twists part of the
fun of shudder island is going back and
watching it a second time and seeing
just how intricately the twist is
layered in thanks Community it was a
great choice for number four we have the
subversive and mindbending Fight Club
throughout the story the audience is led
to believe that the unnamed narrator
played by Edward Norton and Tyler Duran
played by Brad Pit are two separate
individuals do you know if you mixed
equal parts of gasoline and frozen
orange juice concentrate you can make
Napal no I did not know that is that
true that's right one can make all kinds
of explosives using simple household
items the narrator an insomniac office
worker disillusioned with consumer
culture forms a friendship with the
anarchist and anti-materialist Tyler
Duran the charismatic leader of an
underground Fight Club pivotal twist is
revealed when the audience discovers
that the narrator and TI Duron are in
fact the same person David Fincher's
brilliant Direction takes us on an
exhilarating Journey Through the
fractured psyche of the narrator the
film's audacious and provocative
approach cements it as a Timeless
classic and its impact on both Cinema
and pop culture is undeniable one simple
thing why do people think that I'm
you answer
me it's also a film that taught us if
there's a character that only one person
talks to throughout the story there's a
good chance that character doesn't exist
thanks Fight Club number three seven
David Fincher strikes again with seven
our third best Twist of all time this
dark Masterpiece featuring The
electrifying duo in Brad Pit and Morgan
Freeman is a Relentless descent into a
world of unspeakable depravity the best
tenant I've ever had in yeah landlord's
dream paralyzed tenant with no Tong the
twist in seven pushes the boundaries of
suspense and psychological horror to a
whole new level throughout the movie pit
and Freeman are on the trail of a
sadistic serial killer known as John Doe
played by Kevin spy boo Kevin spy Do's
crimes are meticulously planned around
the seven deadly sins gluttony greed
sloth lust Pride envy and wrath after
John do surrenders himself to the police
he willingly admits to his crimes but
demands that the detectives take him to
a remote location to reveal his final
two victims while in the middle of
nowhere doe presents Brad Pitt's
detective Mills with the package upon
opening the package Mills discovers the
head of his wife Tracy played by G P
so I took a
souvenir her pretty head it becomes
horrifyingly clear that John Doe's
master plan was to make Mills the
embodiment of the seventh sin wrath by
forcing him to commit murder enraged and
heartbroken Mills kills John Doe in a
fit of uncontrollable anger fulfilling
Doe's ultimate goal and becoming the
embodiment of the seventh sin it's a
gut-wrenching Revelation that leaves a
lasting imprint on viewers Minds it's
not just a narrative curveball it's a
shocking Revelation that shatters the
conventional expectations of crime
Thrillers a grim reminder that sometimes
evil can be far more Insidious than we
ever imagined what's in the box what's
in the box just a quick friendly
reminder to like And subscribe to new
rock stars turn on those notifications
and please leave a comment below at
number two we have the Sixth Sense ight
shyamalan's master piece featuring a
haunting performance by Bruce Willis
this Supernatural Thriller takes viewers
on a deeply emotional and Eerie Journey
as it unravels the tale of a child
psychologist played by Willis as he
helps to attempt the young boy who can
see and communicate with the dead I see
dead people The Twist is unveiled in the
closing moments of the film when it
becomes clear that Willis himself is one
of the ghosts that the boy sees and
interacts with the entire movie
including Willis's interactions with his
wife has been a postumus journey of
self-discovery and Redemption for him
the twist in the Sixth Sense is nothing
short of legendary a revelation that
redefines the entire narrative and
forces audiences to revisit the film
with fresh eyes shyamalan's subtle hints
and meticulous foreshadowing led to a
shocking climax that tugs at the
heartstrings while sending shivers down
the spine The Twist is not just about
clever plot mechanics it's a profound
exploration of grief Redemption and the
afterlife it is a testament to the power
of storytelling to surprise resonate and
stay with us long after the credits roll
now it's time for some honorable
mentions before we get to number one
these are some other twists that didn't
quite make our top five it's a three
peat for Fincher with Gone Girl where
it's revealed that the seemingly perfect
wife Amy Dunn has orchestrated her own
disappearance and framed her husband
Nick in an elaborate plan to seek
revenge and regain control in their
tumultuous relationship then there is
The Usual Suspects where it turns out
that Kevin spacy's seemingly powerless
character verbal Kint is actually the
mysterious mythical criminal Kingpin
Kaiser so another Spacey film where
Spacey was the embodiment of evil maybe
he was trying to tell us
something boo Kevin spacy and finally we
have the twist in atonement which
revealed that the entire narrative was
manipulated by the protagonist after she
falsely accuses the James maoy character
of a crime he did not commit leading to
tragic consequences for their lives and
their loved ones and now our number one
film twist of all time is The Empire
Strikes Back with perhaps the greatest
parental reveal this side of Mari Povich
you are the
father at the time of Empire's release
Star Wars was an unprecedented pop
culture phenomenon anticipation for
young Jedi Luke Skywalker clash with
Darth Vader the symbol of Pure Evil was
at a fever pitch then in the film's
climactic duel Darth Vader confronts
Luke Skywalker on the cloud Planet
bespin as they engage in a lightsaber
battle Vader event eventually gains the
upper hand and severs Luke's hand but
the true shock comes when during a tense
conversation Vader reveals a truth that
neither the characters nor the audience
saw coming he is Luke's father I am your
father the line I am your father is one
of the most memorable and iconic moments
in cinematic history this twist
fundamentally transformed the story
turning Vader into a more complex
character and deepening the familial and
moral con within the Star Wars saga it
remains a prime example of how well
executed plot twist can redefine a
narrative and leave a lasting impact on
the audience The Twist encapsulates the
essence of cinematic magic capturing the
imagination and emotions of generations
of movie goers The Empire Strikes Back
proves that a well-executed Twist can be
not just an unforgettable moment but a
part of our cultural Consciousness there
you have it folks our top five best film
twists of all time this list as promised
will live on in an infamy for an
eternity until the end of time as the
definitive authoritative list if you
want to see how we came up with these
rankings check out the film ranks
discussion on our break room Channel and
don't forget to leave a comment did we
forget any major twists do you feel our
ranking should be in a different order
let us know and maybe your moment will
make it into a future video for now this
has been this week's film ranks I'm
Hector Navaro signing off or am I no I
am
bye
[Music]